now this a new report says government
lawyers got a secret court order during
the presidential campaign to monitor
communications of a former Trump advisor
The Washington Post says a judge agreed
there was reason to believe Carter Paige
was acting as an agent of Russia
he gave foreign policy advice to the
Trump campaign page claims what he calls
the Clinton Obama regime targeted him
for disagreeing with its foreign policy
Nancy Cordes is on Capitol Hill with a
report that could affect investigations
of Russian election meddling Nancy good
morning good morning we have known for
some time that US investigators obtained
these FISA warrants to monitor one or
more Trump associates but we are now
learning for the first time more
definitively the subject of at least one
of those warrants its Carter page he is
a former foreign policy adviser to the
Trump campaign and he's someone who was
already on the FBI's radar screen
because he was approached by Russian
intelligence agents back in 2013
now FISA warrants are not easy to obtain
if US investigators want to monitor a US
citizen they need to provide a secret
court with evidence that the subject is
acting as a foreign agent possibly to
spy on or conspire against the United
States these warrants are valid for just
90 days and they grant permission to
carry out electronic surveillance on the
subject unnamed officials have told The
Washington Post that this warrant was
renewed more than once by the FISA Court
now Paige himself has denied any
wrongdoing he's told CBS News quote it
will be interesting to see what comes
out when the unjustified basis for those
FISA warrant requests are more fully
disclosed Paige is a investment banker
he advised Russian energy companies and
the Trump campaign actually began
distancing itself from Paige after a
controversial speech that he gave in
Moscow last summer and they began
describing him guys as an informal
advisor another chapter opens up Nancy
thinks